First Credit ever acting which is the
Brady Bunch in
1972. I got my Screen Actors build card
doing that show and we shot at Paramount
Studios and I got to meet
um Elizabeth Montgomery who was also
Bewitched she was the man that Bewitched
and it was amazing to work with the
Brady Bunch because you know they were
my peers but they were also big stars so
it was sort of surreal but uh I'm
forever thankful for that job yeah then
you you performed at the White House
with President Biden and Obama but yes
the picture we have yes from Biden that
was for Greek Independence Day that was
just March 29th oh no I was exhilarated
look at the president look how close he
is that's nerve-wracking that is
nerve-wracking